hey we recently said on the show that as
progressives an important part of
getting through this presidency and
doing what we can to act advocate for
good policies in Washington is
acknowledging when we have something
positive done by the White House and
this is for two reasons number one is
that on some issues Trump sort of all
over the map politics might actually
align with progressive values it might
just be by coincidence but if it happens
then we should applaud that but
additionally if we applaud and Cheer and
show enthusiasm for some of what Trump
does it could actually help to grow the
rift between Trump and his base and
establishment Republicans which is also
good for progressives because it throws
a sort of monkey wrench into what
otherwise might be a pretty United full
steam ahead coalition between Trump and
establishment Republicans if we have
progressives fully jumping on board with
the every once-in-a-while
incident of Trump doing something
progressives agree with it may help to
further the rift between Trump and
establishment Republicans in this sort
of mode of thinking in the midst of all
the horrors of the first 12 days of
Trump in office we have an example of
one of those actions the Trump
administration said yesterday that they
are not going to be repealing President
Barack Obama's 2014 executive order to
protect LGBTQ employees of federal
contractors from workplace
discrimination it doesn't seem like this
should warrant that much applause it
seems sort of like a no-brainer
obviously we should be protecting LGBTQ
people from workplace discrimination but
that's not always a foregone conclusion
when you're talking about the Republican
Party also the Trump White House didn't
even enact this they're just saying
we're not going to go out of our way to
unprotect LGBTQ employees but I'll give
him this one at least for now however
again if we're thinking that Trump's
moves are part of some broader confusion
campaign I do want to remind you that
number one Donald Trump supports what's
called the First Amendment Defense Act
bill which would solely allow
individuals businesses and nonprofits to
discriminate against LGBTQ people
without risk of
legal consequences Donald Trump has
opposed marriage equality in a number of
interviews Trump was against the Supreme
Court national gay marriage ruling he
said to the Christian Broadcasting
Network
sivanna he's even talking to them quote
that was a shocking decision for you and
for me and for a lot of other people so
we have to remember that although we
agree with the specifics of not
repealing this very obvious
discrimination protection order from the
Obama administration
there's many red flags and warning signs
from Trump when it comes to the LGBTQ
community that I don't want to forget
because Trump is doing the right thing
here by not opposing this he did mention
the LGBT community quite positively in
his convention speech so I guess that's
another positive but in terms of who
he's going to put on the court that's
going to be a net negative for the LGBT
community no doubt mark this down as a
thumbs-up though I think this is the
second thing in his administration
that's been positive along with striking
down TPP yeah strike which again was
dead for months anyway but at least it
was a campaign promise that he is
sticking to also I just remembered Trump
has been supportive of North Carolina's
hb2 transgender bathroom law in some
instances although previously he also
said he doesn't care what bathrooms
people use again it's all confusion
he'll say whatever he thinks the crowd
wants to hear it's a wink and a nod to
the most extreme elements of the
Republican base and as Pat mentioned
Trump did just nominate for the Supreme
Court neo Gorsuch who has ruled against
transgender rights and was against the
decision by the Supreme Court to make
state same-sex marriage bans illegal and
obviously Mike Pence is vice president
one of the most dangerous ideologues in
the country literally one heartbeat away
from the presidency I don't want to be
lulled into a false sense of security
that it's all well and good on the
horizon for the LGBTQ community under
Donald Trump but I agree with his
decision not to undo President Obama's
order to protect employees of federal
contractors based on membership in LGBTQ
communities today's show is brought to
you by go daddy where you can buy your
own domain
build a website or use any of Go Daddy's
business tools you can save 30% at try
godaddy.com slash David GoDaddy has
actually been the official host of the
David Pakman show website for many many
many years the 24/7 customer support has
been a very good thing for us I've
called them at really odd times when
we've had website issues and they are
always available they are the largest
domain registrar and whether you have a
new idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to GoDaddy they can do it all thirteen
million customers try it and get 30% off
at try go daddy.com slash david